the next John Forbes Nash is working the
numbers in Houston the next David Tepper
is hedging his bets in London the next
Stephanie Kwolek is concocting a formula
in her lab in Lincoln but one day
they'll all come here at the gateway to
the next transformation of Carnegie
Mellon University The Temper quad this
new addition will be much more than the
physical location for the tapper School
of Business it'll be the expression of
CMU vision for all of campus in the next
25 years if you look at all the grand
challenges that face the world today
whether it's climate change infectious
diseases urban transportation access to
clean water access to good health care
eliminating poverty all of these are
technological problems they are also
human problems the Carnegie Mellon is
uniquely positioned to bridge that gulf
between technology on the one hand and
humanity on the other while the Tempur
quad will join them all in the cut as
hubs on campus it will also give our
university a new gateway welcoming all
visitors through a mix of public art
design and technology it captures the
creativity of our University's heritage
and future The Temper quad will be a
place where the leadership potential of
every student is tapped a home to higher
expectations and deeper insights rooted
in analytics mentoring state-of-the-art
technology personal engagement and
interaction
as the only leading Business School in
the world that doesn't have silo
departments we can offer innovation
based undergraduate masters and PhD
programs that no one else can match the
Tempur quad will enhance the quality of
life and outside the classroom
experiences that are integral to our
students including places to exercise
their bodies as well as their minds the
first new building on the quad will
connect a number of important activities
from different schools and colleges
while housing The Temper School of
Business top-ranked programs will be
offered collaboratively creating greater
cross campus interaction and making the
new space a true university-wide
facility it will symbolize CMU's
interdisciplinary nature in both
education and research the design of the
space will be flexible and adaptable
featuring the largest auditorium on
campus and modular classrooms that
maximize all the possibilities
technology has to offer for all of CMU
students collaboration and connectivity
will be the hallmarks of the tapper quad
along with a comprehensive commitment to
sustainability CMU's leadership and
technology enhanced learning will
coalesce at the Tempur quad particularly
through the university's newly launched
simon initiative which leverages decades
of research rooted in the
interdisciplinary collaboration of
cognitive neuroscience artificial
intelligence and machine learning into
the design of effective courseware
named in honor of the late CMU Nobel
prize-winner Herbert Simon the Simon
initiative will crystalize CMU strengths
to enhance the university's global
impact on learning outcomes open CMU's
rich bank of learning data to the world
and create and lead a global learning
council comprised of worldwide experts
to establish metrics best practices and
standards for learning outcomes The
Temper quad will be home to the center
for innovation and entrepreneurship
connecting the Tempur quad to all parts
of campus sparking CMU's continued
leadership in innovation and
entrepreneurship with the resources
housed on campus in Pittsburgh we can
connect students to our initiatives
worldwide our graduates will continue to
be hired by the most respected and
innovative companies because what I
learned here lasts what I learn here is
science apply to business and nowadays
that's what we do at Amazon all the time
Carnegie Mellon is a great example of
what it means to move forward and our
entrepreneurial spirit of creativity
exploration and innovation will
accelerate fueling our incubator for
startups our technology was critical in
putting a rover on Mars landing disney
and pittsburgh and revitalizing the
region's economy this will be a location
where faculty and students from all
across campus can come to collaborate on
these important problems that that we
face as in business and in society it's
an extraordinary opportunity for our
students our faculty and
Lum 9 let's do this together let's keep
growing and achieving let's break ground